and queen's off the board Now Queens off
the board Hikaru needs only a draw
somehow but he needs a big miracle right
one to convert this into a draw but at
least he can feel safe that he's not
getting checkmated anytime soon but he's
going to lose his Rook Pawn that's on a
dark Square only one side is a dark
Square bishop and here it goes Magnus
breaks that little Pawn chain there
steals The Rook Pawn so now he'll have a
pass Pawn on opposite sides of the board
that's going to be too much for the
black pieces to deal with and four
seconds for Hikaru he has to make a
move whoa Magnus is playing surprisingly
slowly but
Hikaru she look at that speed he's
trying to pre moove but he's running out
of time there's no mouse there's no
mouse and okay hiar